mark cuban's nft company has just been
caught promoting scammy nft projects
there's a surprise in exchange for
millions of dollars in payment shocker
and it has finally caught up with them
and they lost everything everything
except the money they still have that
guys thank god but the 1.7 million
followers on their at nft account was
just nuked into the metaverse they don't
have that anymore and now several people
are looking for a job now all of this
literally happened overnight one day
they're making hundreds of thousands of
dollars on autopilot and the next the
account has been banned and mark cuban
has been accused of scamming people how
did this happen i'm here to tell you
guys today it all started with a twitter
user who goes by the name of topshot
fund and he actually did what no one has
ever bothered to do with nfts before he
did his research he took a look at all
the projects that mark cuban's company
has been promoting in the last few
months and checked if they actually made
money or not now before we get into the
details of this for those of you who
aren't fully in the loop mark cuban and
a partner jason falovich bought an
instagram account called at nft a little
while ago and almost immediately started
using it to shield the absolute
scummiest projects imaginable as long as
you are willing to pay the right price
sort of rug pull promoters for hire if
you want to look at it that way now i
covered this on my show before warning
you guys about this page okay i dm'd the
owner and i was told i could promote an
nft project that i didn't have on his
page if i only had twenty thousand
dollars per post and he said the only
way this would work is if i bought the
five pack deal which was a hundred
thousand dollars and part of the appeal
of doing this is that they don't mention
that these projects they promote are ads
so it looks like they genuinely have
hype now i told you guys at the time
this was super sketchy and you shouldn't
trust these people and it turns out i
was right because our buddy top shot fun
analyzed the performance of these nft
projects that they were promoting for
cash and found that 70 of them
fell in value lost money 10 percent of
the projects were outright rug pulls and
only 25
of mark cuban's company's picks actually
appreciated in price you would have made
money on them what you're seeing right
now is the spreadsheet that was put
together about all these projects they
promoted now basically this means that
the 1.7 million followers were probably
losing money while the people getting
rich on these picks were obviously
mark cuban in the gang as if they needed
more money i mean i guess there's no
such thing as enough money but anyway
this was called out and almost
immediately this post went viral the
team behind at nft immediately started
to do damage control and set up a live
twitter space claiming that it was all a
big misunderstanding and that they were
big on doing due diligence i'm you know
i'm not going to say every project we've
ever promoted is terrible that couldn't
be further from the case there's been a
lot of fantastic projects that have come
through you know we are doing due
diligence on these projects now all i
really can say to this is my own
experience with talking to these guys
behind the scenes as um a pretend nft
project promoter and i can tell you that
i think the only check they were
interested in was the type you give to a
bank teller i mean they didn't ask what
the name of my
board a penguin project was they were
like hey give us the money now baby
check or we don't care that was the
entire vibe of their thing it was like a
copy paste like if you don't have 25k
per post five post minimum
what are you doing here right now
obviously no one actually believes this
but this is kind of what they have to
say because you know you have a big name
like mark cuban involved he's got this
huge brand and you can't have him
promoting a scam right and so a lot of
work has been done to say mark cuban
what mark cuban what we had his name on
the instagram account he was a
co-founder what he had nothing to do
with this apparently rolling stone asked
him if he was involved and he said no he
wasn't involved at all in the operations
basically he didn't know anything didn't
see anything didn't do anything his
co-founders were just running around
without him and you know maybe there's
some truth to that i'm sure mark cuban's
a busy guy i'm sure he's not dealing
with the day to day but my thinking is
he was probably happy to sign the checks
when the money was coming in but all of
a sudden when stuff blows up all of a
sudden mark cuban is nowhere to be found
he disappears and basically everyone
involved in this is acting like that no
one responded to my requests for comment
um nobody responded when you know it was
asked why they didn't say these things
were ads when they actually were you
know all of a sudden nobody's running
the ship right nobody nobody's in charge
when it's making tens of millions of
dollars i'm sure things are fine even
the guy who's sort of the face of this
whole thing jason falovich the guy who
told me i would need to pay 25 000 per
post on his page you might be shocked to
know that he's not in it for the money
and if you do what you love and like i
don't do it for the money i just [ __ ]
loved it yeah i want to work every day
and do that love that's right guys he
has a passion for this this is
he's got a passion for asking for 25k
per post he's not in it for the money
he's in it for the love of the game the
love of nfts guys either way the page
has now been nuked by instagram by the
the holy angels at zuckerberg's hellhole
i really find it disgusting the way
every time every time it turns out it
was always about the money and the price
was you the price was you guys getting
scammed so i hope you guys learned
something about trusting influencers and
please pump the stock zilla if you want
to get ahead of the game as i said i
covered this months before it became a
news story so if you want to get three
months ahead on the news hey subscribe
like it's free thank you so much for
watching see you in the next one